Kyle are you getting any flashbacks to
your court proceedings you know I mean
you look at this and then you look at
how these people like
you just grab the mic yeah might as well
hold it yeah that's a good look you you
look back and then you look how they
tried to they try to get them to go down
these rabbit holes and then they ask
them these like I'm gonna say leading
questions I think they I think they are
leading questions because
they know where they're going to get you
yeah yeah and they don't have any they
aren't preparing them and they they
freak out they freeze they're like how
am I gonna answer this what if I say
this what if I say no they are not
putting they are not sealing it because
like with your example with the Saran
Wrap what if I say no it was not sealed
but then they say what about the Saran
Wrap what about this wasn't there that
on it they're scared if they say no
they're gonna think people are gonna
think they're stupid because they're
like well it was wrapped up so when when
you're we're all I think everybody glued
to that corporate with you and I felt
like there were several times they tried
to get you and you didn't let them get
you I mean did you did you did you get
uh practice did you uh in like Envision
or or were kind of trained with the
questions that they were giving you
there was a couple questions out there
that I didn't prepare for but we did go
through a mock trial uh Dr John
Demetrius she was my jury consultant and
she helped choose my jury and then she
helped set up the mock trials and
that's how we determined if I was
actually going to testify because uh two
of the two of the three panels heard me
testify and the two that heard me
testify got me not guilty and then the
one that didn't hear me testify
um they did they had a mistrial did you
did you testify from the beginning yeah
I wanted to tell my story I had nothing
to hide yeah you were super authentic to
me like you came off a very authentic I
I did nothing wrong I had the truth on
my side and I thought I wanted to tell
my story it came out it came off that
way I think probably to most of us yeah
and then you got a really great meme
where you're pouring gas and crying you
saw that I think you posted that yeah I
put it on a t-shirt
what was the what was the meme I maybe I
should just see the picture
so Kyle basically recounting the story
has an emotional you know recurrence and
uh
when gas prices went through the roof
did you make that or did someone else
make this meme basically it's
Kyle basically you're starting to cry
you know you're holding the gas pump in
front of a car like the gas prices got
you I think somebody else made that Meme
um it's actually really funny because
the left has used that Meme against me
so many times they've made fun of me or
so I just took it and I owned it
I'm not gonna let you guys use my my
face and make fun of me for it so I'm
gonna make fun of myself that's how you
do it that's humility I'm sorry no no
have you talked to Binger at all I have
not talked to fluffer boy at all
nice no I was gonna say we were just
talking about with the Kerry Lake trial
how the media is falsely framing
everything that had to be I mean did did
you know the media was always lying
about stuff before this happened but and
and I have to imagine as you're going
through the court proceedings even
before it reading the media was like
just fiction just pure fiction I mean
you see the things the media are saying
they twist things they use sound bites
and like it's ridiculous they try to get
away with it and in some instance they
do I mean they called me a white
supremacist a murderer vigilante and
none of those are true but with the
Kerry Lake situation they're only saying
parts that they want to say and they're
leaving stuff out they're not they're
not telling the full story and I think
they should be obligated to as as the
media to report people on the facts
forgive me if this is too personal but
like were there people that were close
to you that started seeing you
differently because they were believing
the news instead of you I mean I've lost
a lot of friends and a lot of family
members because they they didn't want to
fall out of like the Click or their
friend groups unbelievable but you know
that's okay because it really shows who
people are as humans and now I have
better people surrounding me yeah that's
the positive way to look at that I
hopefully it's like a curse But like
everyone gets to go through that in
their life where they shed the scan of
their past with the kids you grew up
with and the parents that you know don't
like or don't get along with if you
don't you know maybe you still do but
those people you know when they start to
disagree with you and complain about
your new who you've you're not who you
used to be that's okay because you're
growing and changing as a person I just
hope it doesn't callous any of us
because I've been thinking about that
myself after the last two years they
weren't as wild as what you went through
but like a lot of us have experienced
that in the last few years 10 years and
uh I sometimes I'm like worried like I
don't want to be too callous and not
extend that forgiveness of someone else
who in the future maybe I should still
extend that sometimes it comes full
circle like you'll go through a phase
where you fall out with people for
whatever 20 years and then if you you
know you stay true to yourself it's
inevitably that you can't you can't deny
that reality you know transparent
reality when someone's really who they
are that's I think it's a parent my view
on this is that I think some people are
inherently evil and it's it's true for
sure it's it's I obviously you can look
at child exploitation and stuff and just
know that there are truly depraved
people you can look at I think it was it
may have been Dahmer or Bundy where they
they sat on at court like yeah I know
what I was doing with was evil and wrong
and all that stuff and I deserve to be
in prison or whatever yeah so like they
know what they're doing yeah but then
you look at there are some people like
in my life and I'm wondering if you if I
assume you probably experienced
something like this people who you
thought were really good friends of
yours because the way the the media
decided the story is going just
everything about your friendship
everything you've ever experienced is
meaningless and you are now enemies I've
experienced that personally with people
I've known from my past there's some of
these people where the last thing I ever
said to them was we had a Skate Session
we drank some some smoothies and I was
like bro fist bump Let's Skate next time
I'll see you later and then you know you
don't realize it but it's the last time
you ever hung out but you leave on good
terms and then a few years later they're
on Twitter lying about you smearing you
and attacking you and I'm like you never
knew how evil that person was until they
decided they could profit off of their
knowledge of you or or the fact that you
were friends
that has has something like that happen
to you yeah I've seen that a lot of
times especially with people I've gone
to school with uh in the beginning I was
seeing some articles that they were like
oh Kyle writtenhouse was this like
terrible person who was like violent in
school and I was just like I wasn't
violent in school I dropped out freshman
year I wasn't a senior with you in high
school I did I since then did graduate
but I'm like I was in school with you
for like a year you you don't know who I
am I also dropped out freshman year yeah
back at you now yeah yeah yeah they're
writing they're writing smears and and
like this is a big point of attack for
the left like not going through
institutionalized learning facilities is
like they Point At You and do that thing
from Body Snatchers
oh yeah like and then they they say haha
that proves you're stupid and I'm like I
don't know I'm just running the business
man that's oh I'm sorry I'll just saying
that's how I felt watching a lot of
these defense attorneys today like
almost like laughing at the guy with the
accent like like a they couldn't even
help it you know the Alabama guy yeah
right like it was just like to them it
was like kind of like a joke you know
not all of them but like a few of them
and uh you know earlier they were just
some of them were joking about like what
private schools they went to you know
they're from a different dimension than
me and uh you could see that in the way
they treat other people what if they
really are from a different dimension I
think two two universes collided and
that's why we have the culture War at
least
inter-dimensional demons is what some
people call yo you said you dropped that
but then did you go back to school I I
ended up while I was on trial I did
online school and I ended up getting my
high school diploma the left will attack
people that don't have an education but
they will be some of the most successful
business owners out there yet the person
who has is like 110 000 in debt because
they wanted to get their doctorate
degree or however much it costs yeah
they're uh lesbian dance Theory that's
right right yeah
um I would study that that's just yeah
come on think about it if you if you
were going to study feminist dance
Theory under James Lindsay that's worth
spending money on because he's not gonna
he's not trying to indoctrinate he's
actually breaking down what they're
doing and why they're doing it is he
dancing we're not talking about
feminists Kyle's saying something else
but I'm saying I'm saying like woke
ideology as a whole not just like one
subset of like lesbian dance Theory I'm
saying if if you if you actually took a
study on wokeness and critical race
Theory from James Lindsey he'd give you
a holistic view of what their goals are
what they believe but when you go to the
average college they're actually just
indoctrinating and telling you you know
white people are bad or something like
that and then those people that graduate
end up living off of welfare and end up
doing it nothing with their lives and
living off the government essentially
makes sense yeah I was on welfare for a
while unemployment and then it was hard
to get off because it was like if you
get a job you lose your unemployment I'm
like well I'll make less money out of my
poverty cycle it's like okay so you're
in that cycle and then you're getting
money for the government then you go out
and work and then you're making less
than the government's giving you and
you're like oh well I can I can go
afford this fancy stake right now but
when I'm working I'm living off of
McDonald's because I can't afford that
fancy steak and I have more free time
too on unemployment it was crazy like
you could like they don't want to do
anything to contribute to society and
what is this maybe like 15 years ago I
was on unemployment after losing a job
and they make you call once a week and
you know this is in Illinois in Chicago
and you got to answer questions like did
you look for work yes you know did you
make any money no and um after a few
months was this during covid no no no
this is 15 years ago 15. I was like 22
years ago no no sorry 15. and um I'm
talking to this woman
and she was like okay you know your your
unemployment is up for review or
whatever she said have you been looking
for work and I said I have and she's
like have you found anything and I was
like I'll be honest with you like there
are some jobs I could take probably
because like I'm not trying to be on
unemployment but they pay less than I
was making before and I'm kind of
worried and just no no no no don't take
those jobs she's like the last thing we
want is for you to take a job that pays
less then you find out you can't pay
your bills you lose your job and you're
back on unemployment again and I was
like oh that actually kind of makes
sense she goes you need to find
something comparable so that you can get
back in the flow of things
I think that makes sense but I also
think some people are going to be like
look if you're if you find a job and
you're getting paid you know 50k a year
and then you lose your job going
unemployment then they tell you that
you're never going to get off
unemployment until it's at least until
it expires yeah that's why coven was
beautiful for a lot of people we got
that covered cash the bonus yeah they're
getting free they were getting
unemployment plus the bonus and it was
extended for a year and people were just
not working and that money that they
were getting people think this is like
your tax dollars no no that's modern
monetary Theory they're basically just
extracting the value of your money
that's why inflation is going through
that one of the reasons and a nice
Donald Trump two thousand dollar check
that the government couldn't even roll
out correctly everyone was really happy
about that thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time